I'll film resumes so yesterday we
finished or maybe two days ago I don't
[ __ ] know
we finished walking ahead to season two
a lot of people were upset about the
ending they didn't think I made the
right choice I still think I made the
right choice but I hear there's five
different endings and I'm like hey why
not check them out I'm curious because
there's a lot of things you can do right
so yeah if you're curious like me what
they are then let's do this I don't feel
good going back I don't like this
I can either shoot kami or look away I
don't even get to choose I'll look away
then what's gonna
[Music]
yeah it makes sense actually because he
was the one
it's gone clear
she she just
No
Jesus
seconds till the shoot Kenny oh my god
let's do that next time
ah
go I'm right behind you
not really so why did she do it just to
prove that he was crazy
of course he's crazy he went through so
much way to make it worse like I'd
really didn't like Jane's choice of
doing night
[Music]
how did you get the eyepatch anatta back
look she taken him from I just why would
she she was nuts clam a disturbed person
that had her own agenda that was looking
out for herself
alright
[Music]
hey listen I didn't want that to happen
either
I thought she killed Alvey clam and at
any point she could have stopped what
was happening by saying he was fine she
wanted a fight that's true actually I
never ever hurts you you understand I
was protecting you know you believe me
right
just imagining what she did to Alvey
everything just went black by the time I
got my head straight it was too late I I
believe you okay
I feel bad for you kidding no but still
oh god that oh come on let's put some
miles between us in this place
so I think from my heart from other
people we actually get another scene
here with another choice let's see what
it is 90s later yeah ash
why me buddy what are you doing we just
walk it's just a little further
we're almost there ah sure hope that's a
cook fire oh we could use a hot meal
right about now might be all I need come
on I'll race you to the top hey don't
run with the babba you cheated oh we're
back here how's that even [ __ ] we did it
glamour that's gotta be it oh it's a new
place I can't believe we found it how do
you know the giant wall out in the
middle of nowhere come on that's gotta
be it what are we waiting for come on
this one's gonna be the one look at
those walls finally feel safe clamp be
able to sleep at night whoa so much for
that
just stay still Clem do what she says
put your hands up clam it
drop your weapons
just a couple of people at the front
gate they don't look like trouble how do
they build that Susie I'm Edith names
Kenny
and this year's Clementine hello oh what
a handsome boy look at him what's his
name
Alvin jr. oh he's gonna be a little
heartbreaker when he grows up is there
someone named Krista in there I don't
think so dear so this is Wellington
right a lot of people call it that okay
so what do we do to get in well I'm
afraid this is the part where I give you
the bad news
how's this that's some supplies food
water medicine a first date are you
giving us this unfortunately our
community isn't accepting new members
we're over capacity as it is and there's
just not enough to go around if we keep
bringing people in things might change
[ __ ] kidding me
I'm sorry I really am but we have a baby
it's crazy this lease is hard for me too
I don't want to turn anyone away
especially children but just take the
kids
what please just take the kids it's too
dangerous out here for Kendall he's just
a little girl and a baby boy you can
make room for that you can take back the
supplies you gave us if that helps
please just I need them to be safe and
damage safe in there I know that just
ask someone please it won't make it out
here please
I'll ask just give me a second
you don't need to look at me like that
how are you doing
look at these walls it's safe here you
two will be safe that's what's important
now
we can take the children but just the
children I made the case thank you thank
you I don't want to leave now please I'm
begging you please stay here stay here
where it's safe
where you two will have a chance think
about Alby here please Clem just do what
I asked last time you'll beat people
you'll make friends there's another
decision would I guess leads to another
and being please what do you want have
to sleep with a gun next year every
night you can be a kid for a while
[Music]
okay alright I'll start with this one
please it's safe here you need to stop
okay just stop
it sounds like it sounds like she means
business come on we're leaving I'm only
supposed to give out one per group look
if you're in the area check back in a
few months we might be accepting people
then thank you for the help and sorry
for the language oh it's a shitty
situation we're all doing the best we
can
you all stay safe out there
here is stubbornness damn you
yeah wonder where I got that from
[Music]
and there you go goddamn I got a little
teary
I didn't think I would do again yeah
let's move on to be done two out of five
we got three more think about Alva here
please clamp just do as I'm asking this
one last time you meet people you'll
make friends people good
they don't have to look at you and feel
ashamed it what they put you through
please yeah damn it every time
[Music]
okay
okay mistake
gosh state this is the right decision
okay right he's broke
you tell him about his mommy and his
daddy and all the people who tried to
keep him safe
you tell it okay he deserves to know
I got oh you're here take this
when he when he's old enough you make
him wear it
he'll it will keep the Sun out of his
eyes that's important
all right keep an eye out for
please
now you take care of over here you you
live a good life
Hey
don't waste this okay now I'm gonna go
let it go before one of us for one of us
changes their mind I'm gonna walk away
I'm real glad to have met you
Clementine
[Music]
goddammit
all the endings are I can't oh my god
alright let's try this again I really
don't want to shoot Ken again after all
this this feel awful I'm out of tears
all right don't do this yeah yeah
clam
you made the right choice
I'll let you down I'll let everyone down
why did you make me do this
I'm sorry Clementine
got something in my hair almost made
we were close weren't we
I thought I wanted this nice board so
many times now that is happening I was
here
I'm afraid glamour it's okay can you
you're going to see a cotton duck you're
going to see them again is it busy oh
here always good for a smile
I don't understand how you can choose to
go with Jane after that like she she
wanted to kill him but we're good that's
the decision we're gonna make he's alive
I understand if you're upset AJ was
never in any danger she was just going
to try to talk you into coming with me I
wasn't talking I just thought if you saw
can you like that
you'd know we'd have to leave him she
could've just stopped look Glenn I'm
sorry I didn't think Kenny would go that
far but it's over now
hi I can't believe he's alive he's safe
Glenn feel so fake choosing this is a
stupid plan I should never have lied to
you I thought it was the only way you'd
see me oh my god Kenny you have to
forgive me please we can't just leave
all this behind us please I did it for
you Clem [ __ ] her policy we're free
now
I forgive you Jay
thank you thank you Clem
you were right about Kenny no you're
wrong
you knew what he was gonna do it's over
now Clem [ __ ] it's Jenny like they put
all this behind us
goddamn murderer that's what she is
murderer
okay I think this standing crying told
me about he said they um we're gonna see
it anyway I don't haven't no point of me
telling it
so we've nine days I don't know what's
up with that
can't see much from here come on already
it's so much warmer they got that 49
days oh oh is that who I think it is
Carver I'm glad you didn't have to see
that happen holy [ __ ] did can he do that
oh let's keep moving
oh my god he really took it out huh
here's the food Glenn this formula
bonnie was right
ad thing oh yeah I'm a sip of some foam
in that me greenhouse is in good shape
you know maybe we should stay here a
while see how it goes well sis
that's a weird timing they don't look
armed this your place yeah it is
oh really sassy ken yeah why we need
help my boy he he ain't doing so good
what's wrong with him
look don't worry he ain't he ain't bit
just hungry we've been walking for weeks
ran out of food a couple days back
that's your kid
where you girls been why do you care
whoa I I didn't mean nothing by it
everywhere all over you uh been up north
yeah yeah us to keep your eye on him
this place needs a lot of work yeah can
you some help I guess yeah we could help
you there's not that much food left
please we won't make it another night
out here what do you think AJ look I
know you don't know us and I know a lot
of people out here say a lot of things
but I'm asking you as a father please
don't turn us away
I don't know Clem it could be anybody do
you really want to go through this again
please
okay we'll die out here just give us a
chance Holly my domain first thank you
around the side
to tell about topic girls go grab me
outside the place is a mess and I don't
know how long that food will last I'm
not sure about anything anymore that's
not much but we'll make it better
good luck with that Ajo with seeping
being so soap y'all just keep your eyes
on him I'll be fine
my name's Patricia Jane Thank You Jane
don't mention it
thank you so much of course I'm the one
who made the call where's my hug I'm
really on it back
cool huh yeah thanks that was the worst
ending all right can we talk about that
that ending no all the other endings
like this anything no I'm not feeling it
all right let's see what happens if we
yeah if we don't invite the meeting so
that this is the fifth ending isn't it
one two three four five yeah I really I
really wish they kept more people alive
like oh man and Tricia I guess you're
coming back in next season actually or
Chris says don't worry please sorry
leave what you heard me now goddamn clam
them Todd likes anything he's gonna pull
them are you sure you want to do this
little girl I mean what if what if we're
dangerous then we really Sydney my
dreams what if I slay come on honey
let's go
[Music]
oh he was gonna draw his gun thanks for
doing that after looking at that kid I
wasn't sure if I could but we had to we
have to look out for ourselves now
sometimes you have to hurt someone else
to protect the people you care about the
friend told me that once they might come
back
then we'll be ready Jesus okay then
and that was my least loose favorite
candy I mean yeah okay let's check out
what happens I'm curious what happens if
you kill Trisha Hank end here it is
don't I do it just just do it
oh my god like that so sad I don't want
to gaming alright so she finds the baby
and then we had the same ending I would
that we got the first time I guess
that's [ __ ] up though I hate to leave
it on that note
I'm only doing this because I wanted to
see what something out of different
would happen I'm not okay with this
evening very EJ we're gonna be okay
we're gonna be okay
yeah it's the same any all right well uh
I think you bros variety i really really
preferred the ending where we choose to
save ken but I still think that banding
we got the first time made more sense
considering I don't know not everything
has to be happy and Daffy you know but
it was still very sad and emotional the
night I even cracked up a little bit so
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video and I'll probably keep going with
the one where we could go weekend just
for the for the sake of it thanks for
leaving like bros and that's all for me
for now thanks for hanging out with me
today stay awesome bro